um dia todos primeiramente eu quero
dizer que é uma grande honra
aqui e é é verdade porque eu sempre
procuro me expressar através da pintura
pra mim é muito mais fácil do que as
palavras hoje eu vim aqui pra contar a
história da minha vida
as pessoas me perguntam se eu nasci
artista como as pessoas acham que a
gente nasce bom já se pintando que a
gente já sai com tinta pincel e mas eu
acho que não pelo menos não comigo eu
acho que a gente vai formando a gente
tem que a gente pode até ter o dom
mas isso tem q tem q tem evoluído a
gente tem que estudar a gente tem que
receber informação durante a vida
no início da minha infância eu gostava
muito de desenhar
eu realmente nunca me imaginei pintor
nunca imaginei pintando
mas eu tenho uma paixão muito grande
pelo por desenho a minha forma de contar
histórias ela vem desde a infância eu
sonhava quando eu era pequeno em
desenhar gibi
eu queria ser sócio do ao disney do
mauricio de sousa eu brincava que eu
tinha uma editora uma editora fictícia
que durante a semana tinha que
desenvolveu o roteiro criar personagens
e no final da semana
no sábado quando foi para a casa da avó
que era sempre minha vítima ela ia
comprar esse meu bebê e esse amor
incondicional da avó e eu vou falar um
pouco da minha mãe foram assim muito
importante nesse início da minha da
minha vida porque é foram eles me
apresentaram a de alguma forma
art não estou falando da história da
arte mais da arte de se comunicar
através dos desenhos
a gente vai crescendo e vai talvez
ficando um pouco distante daquele sonho
de ser sócio do dow disney dodô e souza
e de ter uma editora em quadrinhos e mas
o desenho sempre foi uma coisa
importante na minha vida sempre estava
estudando
desenhando no fundo do caderno aquelas
coisas de de moleque quando tinha mais
ou menos 17 anos eu perdi meu pai muito
cedo ea minha mãe achava que eu era a
solução da família porque desejava super
bem que eu ia um dia de desenhar o maior
jornal da cidade de porto alegre
ela teve a idéia um dia de ligar o
jornal fala que ela conheceu um grande
ilustrador um desenhista maravilhoso ela
falou que era o filho dela e que
precisavam que conheci meu trabalho
ela conseguiu uma entrevista onde ela me
acorda diz filho conseguiu uma
entrevista pra você e outra cara de
sonoma onde o que lá no jornal na zero
hora você vai lá e mostra seus trabalhos
em que trabalho mãe que eu vou mostrar
pra eles não vêm cá vêm cá ela pegou um
jornal abril numa mesa e começou faz um
cartoon sobre é sobre esse assunto
então eu olhava vale cultura política e
economia mas de um garoto de 17 anos
fazendo uma charge de economia não tinha
nada na cabeça mas sem querer manter um
portfólio eu não sabia o que era um
portfólio não tinha idéia
mas aquela foi minha primeira pasta de
trabalho
eu fui para a reunião fui super bem
recebido e eles me prometeram que assim
que tivesse uma vaga eles iriam me chama
se tiver alguém da rbs estou esperando
ainda 40 anos essa vaga
sério tá bom não deu certo eu voltei da
entrevista um pouco cabisbaixo e eu
parei
parece que não combina mais com a
conquest mais cara eu parei internet
cachorro quente e juro por deus não
fosse um cachorro quente não estaria
aqui hoje dando palestra para vocês
naquele dia eu acho que só naquele dia
um dono de uma agência de propaganda que
participava do clube dos gurus mês de
porto alegre imagina o cara para não
terem de cachorro quente junto comigo na
mesma hora ele escutou
conversa com um amigo eu estava
mostrando minha pasta dizendo que eu
tinha saído de casa para ir atrás de um
emprego que eu precisava muito e eu
sabia desenhar ponta
ele escutou a conversa e disse eu
escutei você tá dando emprego a liga
aquela cara nem acreditei era claro sim
então toma aqui meu cartão e me procure
o cara de um carrão eu não sei como eu
peguei um ônibus cheguei antes que ele
na empresa
ele fala até hoje também conta essa
história com outras pessoas diz olha vai
chegar o menino aqui e me procurar e da
secretária de gestão ele já está lá em
baixo e sem querer eu entrei na
publicidade eu não tinha idéia do que
era propaganda publicidade um confesso
que achei que o evento de livro que é
pegar livre está vendendo fazendo
propaganda mas acontece que naquela
época não existiam computadores ainda
então precisamos de pessoas para
desenhar as idéias dos publicitários dos
diretores de arte dos redatores
alguém tinha que traduzir aquilo através
de arte
então existe um verdadeiro ateliês
dentro das agências
hoje em dia claro tem computador têm
softwares é o photoshop illustrator
você monta um anúncio em pouco tempo mas
imagine naquela época a gente tem que
desenhar tinha que fazer é da forma como
a propaganda de jornal um anúncio de
revista e foi assim que o conheci a
despertar interesse pelas artes porque
tinha muita tinta tinha muito pincel ele
foi um dos primeiros contatos com a arte
o tempo foi passando e eu de estagiário
cheguei a diretor de criação dessa
agência
depois de alguns anos eu recebi um
convite vim pra florianópolis para
trabalhar também em outra agência de
propaganda e já com um computador tinha
passado bastante tempo e em algum
momento da minha vida me convidar para
uma reunião em que eu precisava criar
uma campanha pra casa cor que é uma
mostra de decoração não sei se vocês
conhecem
e eu pensei em fazer uma coisa diferente
eu sentei na minha mesa computador
grande na frente e é um eu vou largar o
computador e vou fazer um cartaz feito à
mão
eu tenho só essa imagem não tenho cartaz
mas era mais ou menos 11 uma cadeira com
óleos e o conceito da campanha era
convidando as pessoas a ver essa casa
criar vida
a partir dali as pessoas começaram a me
pedisse cartaz para emoldurar e botar na
sua sala na casa deles né
saiu de um cartaz aqueles aguentar fazer
qualquer moldura achei tão bonito
aquilo me despertou a vontade então vou
pintar para você e eu comecei a pintar
algumas pessoas
comecei a gostar da da pintura e fui
levando paralelamente a essa vida de
publicitário e artista plástico não se
conhece a rotina de um dom publicitário
e levo ela intensa nessa saía da agência
às vezes às 8 10 da noite
se eu pudesse ainda queria ver minhas
filhas acordada ficar com elas até
dormiu entrava no ateliê para pintar
depois das 11 da noite e pintava até as
duas três da manhã e por uns dez anos
essa foi a minha vida assim nesse
período começaram a aparecer as
exposições e fui com do gradativamente
por florianópolis foi levando a arte é
cada vez mais longes e aconteceu um
convite para expor em paris
imagina um artista plástico puxa é um
eco nem vocês por em paris é no bairro
dos artistas numa réu lado do museu
picasso aquilo pra mim
nossa era é era econômico era um era um
momento assim que que marcou que foi um
que limitou uma nova fase da minha vida
eu fiz tudo certo pintei as obras
despachei viajei pra paris na sexta
feira cheguei no sábado a exposição é a
segunda curtiu o final de semana do
reseller luva
está segunda-feira foi na alfândega
tirar as obras fechada feriado a posse
de sarkozy mas já no desespero comecei
quando a galeria vamos cancelar vamos
amanhã aberto não imagina já passei
convite pra todo mundo não tem mais com
cancelar só então tá bom então eu fui
numa loja de artigos de desenho e
pintura que não dava pra pintar uma
exposição mas desenhar dava eu passei a
tarde desenhando correios desenhos na
parede e fui receber as pessoas do jeito
que eu podia e um pouco antes do dt ido
convidar juarez machado que é um artista
catarinense que mora em empresa muitos
anos e cara esse cara me ajudou muito
quando ele entrou na exposição olhou
assim o deu errado alguma coisa
expliquei janeiro puxa as orelhas é
aconteceu isso mas amanhã vou trazer as
obras e falou pra mim não me preocupa o
pessoal aqui em paris vem para beber
vinho e não vai nem ver que não são seus
quadros cá e o pior é que assim foi foi
muito legal o tcheco até o embaixador do
brasil apareceu na exposição dos
desenhos mas o final foi que o bem de
todos os desenhos e depois todas as
pinturas o final é feliz mas foi assim
muito tenso né
a partir daí começaram a surgir várias
posições recentemente eu voltei da da
art basel em miami mas tem uma exposição
que marca um novo momento da minha arte
foi ali que comecei a entender que eu
podia pintar o ou colocar na agenda
exposição de mais pessoas numa exposição
em porto alegre é um empresário comprou
dois quadros meus e me deu um cartão lá
em porto alegre as pessoas têm mania de
dar cartão né
ele me deu um cartão de olhão e procura
amanhã de manhã vai lá na minha empresa
eu para que eu vou e vou vender mais
quadro pescar mas chegando lá pra minha
surpresa ele era dono de uma uma grande
fábrica de
confecção de roupa espalhada por todo o
brasil e ele me convidou pra criar uma
linha e foi aí que entendi o alcance que
minha obra podia começar a tomar em vez
de eu contar um quadro no meu atelier
para um cliente que vai pegar vai levar
para sua casa e ele vai sofrer mais do
que todo mundo claro eu podia sim fazer
uma arte colocar uma outra superfície
que hoje eu faço isso em chocolate em
xícara e ventilador intérpete e cada vez
mais chega a mais pessoas
existe um cliente que tem 120 mil pontos
no brasil imagina a dimensão que isso
toma isso pra mim eu acredito nisso eu
sei que nem todo artista pensa da mesma
forma é mas eu acredito eu quero que o
meu trabalho chegue o mais longe
possível porque eu tenho uma mensagem
para passar com a minha obra é eu tenho
uma mensagem de amor eu quero que as
pessoas sejam mais felizes eu sempre
procuro sobre qualquer tema que eu vou
pintar e pintou uma coisa alegre mão um
sentimento quando você vê alguém no
facebook escrevendo comprei meu primeiro
luciano martins parece ele comprou um
quadro e vai investigar porque eu sou
superdetetive facebook é quadra e se lá
em manaus não é no quadro é uma caneca e
aí puxa eu percebo que deu certo a
mensagem foi né
a superfície pode ser uma tela mas pode
ser um quadro e quando você chega em em
outras superfícies mais acessíveis
você começa a chegar também nas crianças
que hoje é um dos motivos para eu pintar
cada vez mais pra eu sair mais tarde no
ateliê chega mais cedo é porque a
criança não compra o quadro mas ela
comprou o artista e para minha
felicidade eu recebo é semanalmente uma
escola por semana na galeria tem escolas
no brasil inteiro estudando a minha obra
e aí começa a entender que essa pode ser
a a minha conta a partida por tudo que o
o que eu vou conquistando ofereci para a
sociedade que é acesso - a arte a
cultura porque de alguma forma eu acho
que são a porta de entrada não quer
dizer que as crianças têm que gostar do
meu trabalho mas meu trabalho é mais
fácil da criança se identificar e depois
ela vai evoluindo para outros gostos é
que tem uma foto mostrando às crianças
mas isso é muito bacana porque deixei a
minha galeria assim iluminada pelo resto
do dia
ano passado foram 86 escolas na galeria
está falando de mais de mil crianças
quando você não percebe uma criança
olhando para uma tela dessa forma você
vê que faz sentido a gente acha que a
criança é não consegue entender captar
todas as mensagens mas acredito em que
as crianças estão lendo todo tipo de
informação o tempo inteiro
eu fiz uma exposição retrospectiva no
cic em que foram muitas escolas lá e
foram quase três mil crianças e essa
foto emblemática é uma foto de uma avó
com o neto de mãos dadas e eu fui
conversar com a sua avó e agradecer por
ter levado netto e ela disse pra mim não
agradeça com o neto é ele que está me
trazendo aqui faz 50 anos que não entra
no museu cara e aí pronto pra mim basta
é o ciclo está completo
essa foto é emblemática são netos e voz
todo mundo curtindo esse sorriso ele
conta muito para mim
mas a partir daí eu entendo que a arte
pode sim ser um agente de transformação
social ela pode dar voz para muitas
causas
eu estou a participando de mais de cem
ongs instituições com causas inúmeras
mas da forma que eu possa contribuir a
forma que eu posso contribuir é
exatamente dando voz pra elas criando
marcas
ajudamos em campanhas institucionais e
eu faço essa doação toda a noite para
uma duas horas por dia
quero melhorar e eu ia bater
é que hoje eu não vou mais estou
chegando em casa pra fazer isso que
conta hoje para vocês assim é que tudo
que eu faço faço com muito amor com com
muito sentimento assim o é o que me
motiva todos os dias a pintar eu pinto
segunda terça quarta quinta sexta sábado
e domingo o tempo inteiro pessoas
pergunta que eu faço quando não estou
trabalhando quando eu estou trabalhando
eu estou pintando que é o meu hobby meu
sonho infantil que foi sempre um é me
expressar através do meu desenho contar
histórias
eu acho que queria ser visto como
exemplo a gente não renunciar a seus
sonhos infantis porque carrega essa
pureza a gente vai crescendo a gente vai
em brothers em duas cidades nos cobra
padrões que as crianças não precisam
seguir mas eu nunca abandona eles e no
final do ano em janeiro
eu junto com o grupo de outros
profissionais
a gente vai lançar um desenho animado da
bubu que é o meu novo personagem da
disney
então demorou 50 anos mas eu tô me
sentindo hoje uma pessoa assim realizada
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]